[Music]
feeling pretty good I want to get this
out of the way up top
I'm dum-dum thank you very much I'm a
dummy I'm a dumb guy I'm a big big old
dumb head D u tu mm see what I did i
misspelled um to illustrate okay but
it's okay here's my point everybody's
dumb listen to me every single person is
dumb everybody hear you're dumb
yeah just own it I like the guy that was
like I like that everybody's dumb some
of you clearly don't like it hey I liked
when he called himself Tom me not as so
much don't be insulted even though it
sounds incredibly insulting it's just
I'm talking about my favorite Mark Twain
quote I don't know if you've heard it he
said we are all stupid
just in different subjects that's a real
quote I'm C relief on some of your faces
when he said Mark Twain quote I was
worried it'd be the one with the n-word
[Laughter]
[Applause]
now they're gonna go
but everybody's dumbing something that's
just how it is you get all A's and all
your subjects except you always fail
French you can cook but you can't drive
great speller lousy surgeon
and he's gone let's play some Scrabble
even Albert Einstein you know that guy
who's so brilliant his name is
synonymous with smart Albert Einstein
the genius Albert Einstein couldn't tie
his shoes
that's true looked it up Wikipedia the
guy who wrote the unified field theory
couldn't remember bunny or bunny a
loop-de-loop
he's like e equals MC squared the
scheisse
get me c flip-flops that's the thing
there's different kinds of intelligence
you could be a genius in one thing but
completely lacking in another area like
social intelligence we all know people
that just have no social intelligence
whatsoever talking to inches from your
face after they just clearly houst a
plate of bluefish pate going around
asking women they barely know if they're
pregnant I thought it was the miracle of
life now my father you've been skipping
the gym dummies no social intelligence
in that way they're dumb but you could
have lots of social intelligence but
that doesn't mean you're not lacking in
another way you could be the smoothest
mother in a bar you know Antonio
Banderas type going up to women like I
must paint you some people aren't book
smart too but they're street smart and
street smarts are great going around
like listen to me somebody comes up to
you and says I bet you five dollars I
can guess where you got your shoes do
not engage he's gonna say your feet and
then chase you down the street for that
sob up that's why I always keep my
wallet in my sock
that's called street smarts
then there's the financial genius Wall
Street guy with no street smarts sure he
can make a million dollars in about
eleven minutes just like don't worry I
moved your oil future to pork-belly
before it tanked then moved it back to
oil future before PB&J went through the
roof
all this before my afternoon cocaine
sauna martini and squash game goodbye
[Applause]
will you drop that same guy in the Bronx
he's the first schmuck to fall for
three-card Monte just like 1 out of 3
those are impeccable odds sir I will put
I don't have my wallet that's why you
gotta put in your sack different types
of intelligence Beyonce right singer
dancer multi-platinum recording artist a
creative genius but not great with
spatial intelligence anybody know what
I'm talking about she has twice gotten
her hair stuck in a fan yeah it's true
it's documented how many times have you
gotten your hair stuck in a fan even if
the answer is one you're still doing
better than mrs. jay-z Steve Jobs - a
hero of mine had great abstract
intelligence creative iPod iPad iPhone
the Newton if you're laughing you're 30
they can't all be winners but no mind
for fashion same guy always wear the
same turtleneck and mom jeans every
keynote just like I want to look like a
mime from here to here and the wife from
home improvement down here
[Applause]
[Music]